while the government's not going to give  you the flear because it's advanced  technology I think that's a little  Hollow these images were taken in 2004  that probably means that Raytheon  technology is over 30 years old right I  mean the FLIR system itself was mounted  on a pod it's not installed as I  understand F-18 so this is not like some  Modern stealth fighter right this is a  pod that's external to the original  airframe am I right  we're talking about you know  but on to that many really secret  technological things that are hidden and  a lot of it was actually described in  the patterns which I read in great depth  that they describe to some degree the  internal workings of the system and how  it uses these gimbal mirrors internally  to steer the line of sight and how it  has this external Gimbal and how they  work together it's not like we know  nothing at all about it but it'd be good  to have confirmation